esta falta de sintonía entre el gobierno
colombiano el gobierno del presidente
Petro y el eln en cuanto a estos
supuestos acuerdos de cese al fuego que
deja en evidencia y esto Cómo puede
afectar Esa mesa de diálogo que Avanza
en la ciudad de Caracas
Santiago Un saludo para ti y para toda
la audiencia de veinticuatro y desearles
un buen año yo creo que lo que hay de
fondo en esta situación de de distensión
que ha planteado el presidente Petro con
una propuesta de ciencia bilateral a
cinco grupos que se entendería como
acciones de la fuerza pública acciones
ofensivas de la fuerza pública
y la reacción del eln tiene como
contexto que tanto el eln desde el 7 de
agosto que fue la posesión del
presidente
está en un cese unilateral de acciones O
sea desde el 7 de agosto para acá No hay
acciones militares del Elena hacia la
fuerza Pública han habido algunos
algunas situaciones de
retenciones de miembros de la fuerza
pública que han sido liberados pero
realmente si se compara con los meses
anteriores del gobierno Duque hay una
distensión de parte del Elena Entonces
yo creo que en el fondo lo que hay es
una interés tanto del gobierno del
presidente como el eln de generar una
negociación en el marco de un de
distensión me parece lo importante y en
la próxima ronda en México las dos
partes gobierno y eln podrán avanzar en
establecer de manera formal este cese
bilateral Sí justamente la guerrilla del
eln ya se mostró abierta a hablar sobre
este tema de un cese al fuego formal con
el gobierno colombiano señor salir le
preguntó qué análisis hace usted de esa
ambiciosa o ese ambicioso plan de paz
Total que ha propuesto el presidente
Petro cree que es una política que está
descuidando un poco los acuerdos ya
alcanzados con la guerrilla de las FARC
y que se afana un poco por Mostrar
resultados avances con la guerrilla del
eln y con otros grupos armados Cuál es
su análisis
el gobierno del presidente Petro tiene
un compromiso firme con con el acuerdo
con las Farc recordemos que el primer
punto del acuerdo con el alfal es el
tema del desarrollo rural y en eso y el
gobierno ha dado los más importantes
pasos que no se hayan dado en décadas al
proponer la compra a los ganaderos de
tres millones de hectáreas en la
propuesta de del acuerdo de paz con La
FARC hay un fondo de un millón
quinientas mil hectáreas para ser
repartida entre campesinos pobres y lo
que ha planteado ya de manera concreta
el gobierno es la compra de tres
millones de detalles que se podrán hacer
los próximos seis millones seis eh seis
años entonces hay una hay evidencia que
este gobierno tiene compromiso con el
acuerdo con las Farc
y segundo la política de paz total pues
tiene que ir hacia todas las violencias
organizadas en Colombia persisten
fácilmente 20-30 estructuras organizadas
haciendo violencia y hacia ellos va a
dirigir la política de paz total
entonces este año va a ser decisivo para
esa política y el compromiso del
gobierno es trabajar con las comunidades
y los territorios para lograr una
Colombia en